When you think fact tables,
your goal is to keep them long and thin.
A fact table will have one row per event.
Think back to that grocery store checkout with each beat
creating a new row in your sales transactions fact table.
Additionally, fact tables need to have
consistent granularity or level of detail regarding their data.
You should not have data that summarize a month of
transactions mixed in with second-by-second transactions.
This creates inconsistencies in how the data can be presented,
and can put you at risk of double counting data and other inaccuracies.
Fact tables should have one key column for each dimension table that you plan to use.
But it's entirely okay and expected for those key column values to repeat.
If we use the grocery store example from earlier,
you might remember that the sales list of
individual item transactions would be your fact table,
and sales for Gala apples might show up thousands of times in a given day.
So the PLU number for Gala apples would repeat many times.
However, you want to minimize adding any additional columns beyond this minimum.
Fact tables are high-volume and you want the weight in bytes that
the fact table is going to gain over time to be reserved for the additional rows.
Note that this can make a fact table hard to
read on its own because if you've done your job right,
you're essentially stripping it of everything that isn't a number or a key column.
This is okay. Fact table data is never experienced without the dimensional details.
Dimensions tend to really be the inverse of fact tables.
So when you think of dimensions,
think short and fat.
Unlike the fact table,
your dimension table will have
just one unique key value listed that corresponds to the fact table.
Just like you wouldn't know for sure
which Granny Smith apple to buy if you
were presented with two options at the grocery store,
your data model won't know which key value to
attribute transactions to if there's any ambiguity.
However, since the dimension table is designed to have as few rows as possible,
you can get away with more calculated or conditional columns when you need them.
Something you can take advantage of in either a Power Query or index.
Additional columns are very cheap in comparison for dimensions.
Finally, we want to ensure that we use human friendly column names and values
because all of these will be used for
the reporting purposes and that is where it's all going to be reflecting.